hey everyone it's sarah with
registeredness rn.com and in this video
i'm going to be going over the rights of
medication administration
and whenever you get done watching this
youtube video you can access the free
quiz that will test you on this content
so let's get started the purpose of the
rights of medication administration
is to help prevent medication errors now
as a nurse
we are the last safety net in medication
administration
because most of the time we are the ones
who give the patient the medication
so we always want to double check or
even triple check
the medication that we are giving the
patient by
following these rights now these rights
are very helpful
and as a nurse i have actually caught
many medication errors by just following
these rights of medication
administration for instance i have found
a medication that was ordered on a
patient
pharmacy put in the wrong dose or the
wrong frequency
or a physician had accidentally put in a
medication order on a patient that was
meant for another patient
and i simply just looked at that
medication i was like why is this
patient being ordered this medication so
i was following the right reason
turns out it wasn't even for that
patient also whenever i've went to
remove medications
from like a system that was created to
help prevent medication errors the pixis
system
it actually dispensed me with the wrong
medication and what had happened
was that the medication it had dispensed
me with had a very similar name to
another drug so whoever
had stalked the system had accidentally
put in the wrong medication
so errors do happen even in today
whenever we have all this technology
that's supposed to assist us with
medication administration so we always
want to make sure
that we stick to the basics and we
follow these rights
now the rights of medication
administration have really evolved over
the years
we have the five basic rights that
really lay that foundation for what we
need to know whenever we're
administering medications but there's
other rights that have been added on
over the years just to help
increase our safety checks whenever we
are giving a patient medication
so you may have heard of the seven
rights the nine rides the ten rides and
etc so what i want to do is i'm going to
cover the five basic ones which help
layer foundation for medication
administration and then i want to talk
about the other ones that have been
added on over the years
so the first right we have is called the
right
patient and as a nurse we want to make
sure that we have the right
patient for this medication because
sometimes on a unit you're going to have
a set of patients
that have the same first name or the
same last name or even the same
first and last name you want to ensure
that this medication that you're giving
the patient is for the right
person so to do that we're going to
perform some safety checks
and we want to use at least two
patient identifiers so you could ask the
patient to state their first
and last name along with their date of
birth
and take that information that they've
given you and compare that to their
arm identification band that they're
wearing and then take it a step further
and
look in that medication administration
record the more
and see if that information matches up
next is the second right which is right
medication
now whenever you're performing your
safety checks for this right you want to
look at that order and you want to pay
close attention to
that medication name that was ordered
and compare that
to what you have on hand what you've
been dispensed with
and look at that name from beginning to
end very carefully and
analyze it and make sure it matches and
the reason i really stress that is
because there are medications out there
that have very similar looking names and
if you take like a quick glance at it
you may miss
the difference and think it is that
medication for instance look at these
two drug names
we have acetazolamide which is a
diuretic
and then we have acetohexamide which
helps treat diabetes and
lower the blood glucose now if you just
quickly glance at these medications you
may
miss the difference and think it is that
medication that was ordered
now furthermore what you want to do
whenever you're going over this right
medication
is that you want to make sure that that
medication you're giving
isn't expired that it's within date that
it hasn't been damaged
tampered with or anything like that it's
good to go and give to the patient
and you just want to look at the
patient's allergies and
just ask them what they're allergic to
just to confirm that
and even take it a step further and ask
them
you know i'm giving you this have you
ever had this medication in the past if
it's not one of their home medications
that they take regularly
and ask them if they have well did you
do okay with it did you tolerate it okay
because that can
help tip you off as a nurse you know i
need to be watching out for some
potential side effects that could happen
that they may have had in the past the
next right is the right dose
so just like before with the right
medication you're going to look
at that order and you're particularly
paying attention to the dose that was
ordered
and you're going to compare that with
what you plan on giving
is this the right dose and many times
you're not going to be dispensed with
the right dose
you're either going to have to take the
medication and split that pill in order
to equal what was ordered
or you're going to have a vial of
medication and you only need to give
one meal it may have five but you only
need to withdraw one meal
or you may have a drip hanging and let's
say it's a heparin drip
and the ptt is a certain level and you
have to titrate that drip so you're
going to have to do some math in order
to determine based on that patient's
weight
with their ptt level with what you're
supposed to set the rate at
so you'll have to do some math so you
definitely want to double check your
math
and you want to get another nurse to
verify with some medications that's an
automatic thing you have to get another
nurse to sign off
on what you have calculated but if
you're ever unsure
it just only takes a second just find
another nurse have them double check
your math then we have the fourth right
which is the right route
so with this again look at that order
but this time pay close attention to the
way
that this medication needs to be
administered so the route
now today we can get medications various
ways
um most common way of course is through
the mouth
but we can also give them iv intravenous
we can give them sub q and the fatty
tissue of the skin
in the muscle im topically etc
so you want to make sure that you have
the right supplies for the way
that you have to give this medication
for instance if a patient's
getting something through the mouth
let's say they're getting a pill you
want to confirm that this patient can
swallow properly you want to make sure
that they have something to take the
medication with
and if they can't swallow what do you do
well can the
can the patient take the medication in a
pudding or an applesauce
or can the medication be crushed and you
give it to them that way so you want to
confirm
if you can indeed crush it and they can
swallow
or let's say you're giving it iv well
you want to make sure
your iv access works because sometimes
they don't work and
you've got to start a new one so you
want to flush it beforehand to confirm
that
give the medication and then flush it
again to make sure you've flushed it
through
or if you're giving this i am you want
to make sure that you're selecting the
appropriate size muscle
for this drug and that you have got the
right size needle
for that muscle or if you're giving it
topically on the skin
you want to look at where the previous
topical application was if the patient's
getting this
routinely you want to make sure that you
remove that
clean that area and then switch where
you put this so you always want to make
sure that you are just being prepared
with the route that you are giving this
medication and then next we have the
fifth right which is the right time and
the right frequency
so with this before you even give that
medication look in that mar that
medication administration record
and see when this was last given
especially if you're giving a prn
medication one of those as needed
medications
and make sure that the frequency that
the patient is receiving this medication
matches up with that original order
so make sure that the medications do
you're not giving it too
late or too soon and pay close attention
to those
time critical medications like
antibiotics anticoagulants
insulin etc because it's very important
at the times you give those
so review the policy at your hospital
that you're working because they're
going to outline
those time frames when you can give
medications when they're not too late or
too soon and these time critical
medications now let's talk about some
more rights of medication administration
that goes beyond those five basic rights
that i just covered
these are also things that you want to
do during medication administration
to ensure patient safety but to also
guide you
throughout the process okay so we have
the right reason
this means whenever you look at the
medication name
as you're giving meds you want to be
asking yourself okay
why is this ordered so think back to
pharmacology
think okay what does this medication do
um how does it work in the body what am
i monitoring for
and what could this be treating in the
patient a lot of times it's going to be
something that's in the patient's health
history so they come to the hospital
they have a history of diabetes so
you're giving them these medications
or there's something currently going on
with the patient and they need this
medication
to treat what's going on with them so
for instance
you have a patient they came to you they
are in right-sided
heart failure and they have fluid
throughout their body they're in fluid
volume overload they have
three plus pitting edema they can barely
breathe because they have so much fluid
in their lungs
you can hear crackles throughout so the
physician orders
iv furosemide lasix so
as a nurse you're going to say okay
right reason what am i thinking okay
we know that this is a loop diuretic how
it's going to work is it's going to
remove all this extra fluid that's
hanging out in this patient's body
into the urinary system so they're going
to be voiding a lot so i need to make
sure that they can get to the bathroom
easily and they have access to it
and let them know that this is going to
be occurring it's normal
and i want to make sure that we're not
dehydrating them like removing too much
fluid so we want to be looking at their
vital signs like their blood pressure
their heart rate and we want to make
sure that we're not wasting too much
potassium because we know that loop
diuretics
waste potassium so physicians are going
to be ordering
routine labs on these patients and your
job is to look at
those lab results as they come in and
make sure they're within normal limits
so before you give them their next dose
of lasix
make sure that their potassium is in
normal
limits a lot of times they're going to
be taking some more potassium
like potassium supplements but we want
to make sure it's good enough because we
don't want to make their potassium level
just
sink too low and a normal potassium is
about 3.5 to 5 milli equivalents per
liter
and then we have the right assessment
okay so
before you give any medications you you
look at the medications
with the right reason but you also want
to ask yourself okay what information do
i need to know
before i actually give this patient this
med because you don't want to give them
this
medication and be like oh no i shouldn't
have gave them this because
this isn't good so let me give you an
example your patient's taking a beta
a beta blocker this helps um this will
slow down the heart rate
so you want to make sure before you give
them this beta blocker that their heart
rate was in
within normal limits before you actually
gave it to them so make sure they're not
experiencing severe bradycardia or
let's say your patient is due to get
some warfarin which is an anticoagulant
coumadin
you want to make sure that you looked at
their latest inr result make sure it's
within parameters of where that
physician
wants them to be and if it is
you can administer it if not you need to
notify the physician
then next you would want to make sure
you're giving the
right education to the patient so this
is a great time
during whenever you are giving
medications to be educating your patient
about these drugs routinely instead of
just throwing this
all on them at discharge because it can
be very overwhelming
so you want to go over the name of the
medication you're giving the patient
um the generic name and the brand name
as well
the frequency how many times a day
they've been getting this
if they are going to go home on it how
many times they would be taking it
the times you've been giving it there
why they're taking it what's the purpose
of this what is this treating
the dose that they're taking and what is
normal versus abnormal
like what should they be monitoring
themselves for like
common side effects versus this is not
good you need to report this to your
physician
and how to administer it let's say that
they're going to be going home
on lovenox and oxaparin so you want to
make sure that you
have demonstrated them how to administer
that and you watch them
do that so they'll be prepared whenever
they go home to take
these medications and the next we have
the right documentation
so this is when we will document the
information
that is needed for whenever we are
giving medications
and this is going to be after
administration and remember to always
document
because there's a saying that says if
you didn't chart it you didn't
do it because if no one can see it
there's no way to tell
that you had done it even though you did
do it and
documenting is a great communication
tool for other people
who are going to be taking care of that
patient for instance let's say
the other shifts coming on and or the
patient's being transferred to another
unit or the patient's going home
this communicates to the other nurse
what medications the patient's been
taking and the last dose and this is
really important
let's say for those prn medications a
patient needs some pain medication
well the nurse can look back at your
documentation and see when you gave it
last and is it due
can they have it again so whenever you
are documenting
some things you definitely want to
include you want to include the name of
the medication you gave the dose
the time you gave it the route you gave
at the site let's say it's one of those
medications like a fentanyl patch
and you put it on the right
side of the body let's say the right arm
or something like that
that tells the nurse who has to
administer the next fentanyl patch where
to go to remove the previous fentanyl
patch
so she can remove that and then apply
the new one so that's very helpful
and any data that needs to be recorded
whenever you
are giving a medication like any lab
levels and we talked about that over
here
any vital signs if the patient's
having pain medication you need to know
the patient's description like words
they're using to describe is a throbbing
stain
cramping uh the location of the pain
their pain rating on a scale
one to ten and follow up
with uh like that pain rating let's say
you gave him some morphine
well you're going back to evaluate it
did the morphine help and see what their
pain rating decreased to
then we have the right to refuse so
patients always
have the ability to tell you that i
don't want this medication so
if you are facing that with a patient
just make sure you have taken the time
to educate them
about why this medication is prescribed
and ask them why they don't want to take
it investigate it because it may be
really simple and maybe they just didn't
know something about
this particular medication and you just
can explain that to them and they're
like oh okay yeah i understand now
i'll take it but whatever the reason is
always make sure you document this
thoroughly and communicate it to the
the prescribing physician if the patient
does refuse to take it
and then lastly we have the right
evaluation
so as a nurse you're definitely going to
want to make sure that this medication
is having the right effect on this
patient
so again this release you can go back to
the right reason whenever you're
thinking of the right reason of the
medication
you're thinking okay how this medication
works on the body
what it's going to do and this is going
to help you with your right evaluation
so example let's say your patient had
uncontrollable atrial fibrillation so
you had to start them on a cardism drip
what is the right evaluation of this
drug how as a nurse do you expect
this drug to be working for this patient
well it should be slowing down that ray
it should start controlling that atrial
fibrillation and it could even help get
them back
to normal sinus rhythm so you'll be
looking at their
heart heart rate their rhythm on that
cardiac monitor
you're also going to be making sure
we're getting the right effect on their
blood pressure
so make sure their blood pressure is
within normal limits
so that helps guide us with that now
don't forget to access the free quiz
that will test you on this material and
thank you so much for watching